Welcome to Planet Earth.
She’s got the toughest streets around, and
if you’re not careful, that mean old missy
won’t hesitate to wash out her gutters with
your blood and decorate the sidewalks with
your teeth.
It’s a tough world for the good and innocent,
with the looming shadow of crime lurking around
every corner, just waiting to prey on those
who are unable to defend themselves.
If you don’t have the tools to survive,
it’ll chew you up and spit you out like
a wad of stale chewing gum.
That’s why we need a hero.
A dark defender.
A cloak in the night.
We need…
The Specter.
New Delhi, India.
A woman walks home from her late-night job.
She’s exhausted, she can feel the bone-deep
ache of fourteen hours on a factory line,
running herself ragged to support her three
kids back home.
She can barely stand; can you really blame
her for wanting to take the shortcut down
that dark alley, knowing it’ll shave fifteen
minutes off her trip?
She ducks in, clutching her purse tight and
keeping her head down, but it won’t do any
good.
A predator has been laying in wait.
He emerges from the darkness, wielding a huge
knife, and grabs her by the shoulder.
He’s a few heads taller than her, with arms
thicker than her neck.
He tells her to hand over the money she’d
spent all month working for, or he’d turn
her kids into orphans.
His knife had tasted blood before and he’d
have no problem killing again.
With tears streaking down her face, knowing
it’s futile to resist, she reaches out and
passes him the money.
The bandit snatches it from her trembling
hand and snickers.
Candy from a baby.
He’s ready to turn around and make a run
with tonight’s takings when he feels an
odd chill drift into the alley.
A soft whoosh.
He turns and sees a figure standing and watching
him.
He’s tall and well-built, with a long, black
coat and a black wide-brimmed hat.
He was darker than the dark: Light seemed
to disappear into him, a black shape against
the background.
It’s him.
The man that all criminals know and fear,
all over the world, even if they’ve never
met him.
The intrusive thought, the moment of creeping
doubt that slithers into their minds the second
they even contemplate breaking the law.
The bad guys’ boogeyman.
The Specter.
“Halt, evildoer!”
the Specter commands.
“You’ll return this fine lady’s money,
or you’ll suffer the consequences.”
The bandit feels a tremor of fear quiver through
him, but he won’t back down.
Not yet.
He charges The Specter with his blade, slashing
like a madman, but not a single hit lands.
The Specter weaves perfectly away from every
strike and effortlessly disarms the bandit
with a perfectly-placed whack to the wrist.
The knife clatters to the ground.
He discombobulates the bandit with an open-palmed
strike to either side of his head, then knocks
him out with a laser-focused headbutt.
He crumples to the ground, unconscious, and
The Specter breathes a sigh.
Another battle won.
This whole time, the woman has been watching,
frozen in awe.
The Specter picks up her stolen money and
hands it back to her with a gentlemanly doff
of his wide-brimmed hat.
He really is just darkness underneath.
Unseeable, unknowable, a living shadow.
She thanks him, and he assures her that it’s
all in a day’s work for a crimefighter like
him.
After all, somebody needs to do it.
And in a flash of smoke, he’s gone.
The woman makes it home safely that night.
London, England.
A man lays beaten and bloody on the ground.
Three assailants surround him, circling like
hungry wolves.
One wields a long lead pipe, still slick with
the man’s blood.
Another, a switchblade, that he keeps clicking
in and out of the handle.
And the third carries a handgun.
The same handgun he’s used to take two lives
before.
The wounded man on the ground - with bruises,
cuts, a broken ankle, a broken wrist, four
broken ribs, and three missing teeth - is
desperate and afraid.
He’s here because he was forced into a corner.
He needed to borrow money from a dangerous
man tucked away in a dingy building in London’s
East End, the city’s organized crime epicenter.
The money he’d borrowed came with predatory
interest that he couldn’t pay back.
Now, he’s paying the difference in blood
to that same loan shark’s violent goons.
The man with the gun, in a thick cockney accent,
tells him that this is why he shouldn’t
have messed around with Mr. Ford.
Now he’s going to be an example for anyone
else stupid enough to think they can stiff
the big man on a payment and live to tell
the tale.
He nods to the man with the pipe to finish
the job.
The beaten and bloodied man on the ground
closes his eyes as the goon steps closer,
lifting up the red-stained pipe and preparing
to finally cave his pitiful head in with it.
In the dark, he hears the whoosh of the pipe’s
downswing, and the breeze hits his bruised
cheek, but the pipe never connects.
Instead, there’s a chorus of gasps.
The man on the ground opens his eyes to get
a better look at what on earth has happened.
A tall, dark man in a long, black coat and
a wide-brimmed hat is standing over him, holding
the lead pipe that he just easily snatched
from the hands of its previous user.
The goons are all stepping back.
The gunman raises his pistol.
The other, his knife.
All of them look afraid.
The man on the ground doesn’t know the stranger
who just saved his life, but in his presence,
he feels something wash over him that he hasn’t
felt in a long while: Safety.
It’s him.
It’s The Specter.
“You wretched villains.
Don’t you know better than to pick on the
weak, a bunch of ‘tough guys’ like you?
How about fighting someone your own size?”
In a blind panic, the gunman raises his pistol
and fires.
The Specter moves like smoke in the wind.
He dodges the bullet and tosses the lead pipe.
It sails through the air and hits the gunman’s
skull with an almighty crack.
He collapses, dropping his weapon.
The other two goons bum rush him, but it doesn’t
serve them any better.
One slashes, the other punches.
With a few skillful, fluid movements, he guides
one goon’s knife-wielding hand into the
other’s shoulder, then disables both with
a pair of simultaneous chops to the throat
that Jackie Chan himself would be proud of.
All three goons are laid out on the ground,
either writhing and gasping or knocked out
cold.
The Specter straightens his coat and hat with
practiced finesse and returns to the man laying
on the ground.
After checking that he was still alive and
conscious, he passed the man a wad of cash
and a phone, telling him to call an ambulance
and get his wounds treated.
None of those men would ever bother him again,
and if they or any others dared to, then they
could expect to see the dark figure of The
Specter appearing behind them in their bathroom
mirror.
After all, someone needs to be there to fight
crime, even when nobody else will.
New York City, USA.
Things are going sideways at a major bank
downtown.
A group of well-armed, highly organized robbers
has broken in.
They’ve taken at least fifty hostages throughout
the building, and have informed the police
blockade outside that unless their demands
are met and they’re given free passage out
of the building, they’ll start executing
people left and right.
And given the ruthless organization of this
particular criminal crew, it seems more than
likely that they’ll put their blood money
where their mouth is.
Police squad cars form a horseshoe blockade
around the building outside, armed with handguns,
shotguns, and assault rifles.
Police snipers are finding their ideal perches
in the surrounding skyscrapers.
SWAT is on its way and a police helicopter
circles above.
However, even if everything goes right, the
higher-ups know that some fatalities are basically
inevitable.
Crews of hardcore career criminals like this
wouldn’t go down without a fight.
One way or another, some lives would be taken
today.
Another transmission is delivered from the
inside after that: The robbers know that time
isn’t on their side, so they’re flipping
the script.
Five minutes, exactly.
If their demands aren’t met by then, blood
would be staining the bank’s immaculate
marble floor.
Tick tock.
The negotiators on the front line are in a
cold sweat.
Five minutes!?
No, that isn’t enough time.
We can’t mobilize, it’ll be a massacre
in there!
How could ten greedy maniacs with assault
rifles pull the rug out from under them all
like this?
Panicked thoughts swim through the head of
a sergeant heading the blockade.
He can’t concede, his superiors would never
allow it.
Does he wait five minutes and see what happens,
or authorize his officers to breach the front
doors, try to reclaim the bank, and potentially
create one of the worst bank robbery bloodbaths
in New York City history?
Damned if he does, damned if he doesn’t.
And every second, the time to decide runs
out…
That’s when he hears a soft whoosh behind
him.
Paranoid enough to jump at shadows, the sergeant
turns, reaching for his gun, and sees what
seems to be a dapper shadow standing right
behind him.
A tall man, with a long, black coat and a
wide-brimmed hat.
No face, just darkness itself under the shade
of the brim.
The stranger places a calm hand on his shoulder,
and suddenly, a sense of trust like he hasn’t
felt in years just sets in.
Somehow, deep in his marrow, he knows this
man is here to help.
“Rest assured, sergeant, everything is under
control now.
For I, The Specter, have arrived to save the
day.
How many criminals are inside?”
The sergeant murmurs ten, in awe.
The Specter nods.
“Worry not, sergeant.
Nobody will die today.”
And with that, like the ghost that is his
very namesake, The Specter is gone.
Inside the bank, the leader of the robbers
checks his watch.
Two minutes, and still no word from the cops
outside.
He’s starting to lose his patience.
A few unfortunate bank tellers and customers
crouch around him, their hands behind their
heads.
Five of his men are out here with him, armed
and keeping the situation under control.
The other four have cracked the security on
the vault and they’re hauling out money
by the bagful.
And still, silence from the cops.
He sneers, and the thought crosses his mind
that perhaps if he takes out a hostage or
two now, the mooks out there might actually
take his threats seriously.
That thought amuses him.
Yeah, that’ll show ‘em.
They’ll finally know who they’re dealing
with here.
The leader shoulders his assault rifle and
draws a bead on the hostage sitting closest
to him.
Even his men are shocked by the suddenness
of it all, but they know better than to second
guess their boss at a time like this.
He was always a little trigger happy…
The hostage - an older gentleman who’d only
come into the bank to check his balance, cause
he hadn’t figured out how to do it online
just yet - sees the gun and winces.
He survived ‘Nam, and this was how he was
going to go.
Gunned down on a Wednesday afternoon by some
creep for chump change.
What a world.
The leader’s finger curls around the trigger,
but before he can complete a squeeze, an expertly-aimed
fist collides with the back of his head, knocking
him unconscious in a single strike.
The leader collapses, his rifle sliding across
the ground.
The Specter stands where he stood, straightening
his coat and blowing dandruff off of his knuckles.
“Are you fellas ready to dance?” he growls.
He glides through them, moving with the grace
of a prima ballerina and hitting with the
force of a freight train.
The goons are down before any of them can
fire a single shot.
With the help of some quick-thinking bank
tellers, The Specter closes the vault door
from the outside, trapping the remaining four
robbers inside.
Textbook crimefighting once more.
The bank customers and employees, weeping
with joy and relief, thank the Specter for
saving their lives.
He shakes his head and assures them it was
nothing.
Just doing what he could, as any concerned
citizen should.
He would have left after that, were it not
for one little problem.
The NYPD has a number of employees at different
levels of their sprawling structure that are
actually deeply embedded undercover agents
of the SCP Foundation.
And this isn’t a comic book.
There’s a word for when a mysterious man
made from darkness appears from nowhere, and
effortlessly takes down ten heavily-armed,
highly-trained combatants by himself, and
that word was “Anomalous.”
Knowing what this mysterious combatant was
capable of, the Foundation sends some of their
best Mobile Task Force Operatives to apprehend
him, under the guise of just being standard
SWAT Team members sent in to get the situation
back under control in the aftermath of the
robbery.
However, much to their extreme surprise, The
Specter puts up absolutely no resistance to
them.
He understands that the men here to apprehend
him are servants of law and order, and would
not defy their will, but he pleads with them
to reconsider.
“You don’t understand, sirs, you’re
making a huge mistake,” he says, distraught.
“I’m here to help.
I’m The Specter, defender of the innocent,
scourge of the evildoer.
You can’t lock me away!
You can’t!
The people need me!”
As tragic as it is to see a genuinely benevolent
anomaly beg for his freedom, the Mobile Task
Force’s hearts have long since hardened
to this kind of thing.
He wouldn’t be the first sapient humanoid
anomaly to speedrun all seven stages of grief
on their knees in front of them, and he probably
wouldn’t be the last.
Foundation protocol is to tag and bag either
way, even if they’d just used their anomalous
abilities to thwart a bank robbery.
The Specter is hauled back to the nearest
Foundation Containment Site and held in a
holding cell while researchers prepare to
conduct initial tests and questioning.
Everything seems so run of the mill - Little
do they notice, something extremely strange
is starting to happen to New York City beyond
the containment chamber’s walls.
They’re about to learn the true, devastating
consequences of keeping a pure force of good
like The Specter locked up.
Like a switch has been flipped, nearby police
suddenly become oddly listless.
Instead of working, they just chat with each
other and random citizens about the weather.
Some watch SCP Explained on their phone while
active robberies are happening.
A man is mugged right in front of a squad
car and the cop inside just listens to his
Van Halen CDs at max volume.
In actual precincts, the on-duty cops start
to wonder why on earth they’re actually
here.
In this building, all together, listening
to phone calls from weirdly panicked people
and typing up reports on…
Stuff?
It all just seems oddly confusing.
They decide to go outside and watch clouds,
or go home and play video games.
It doesn’t make any sense that they’re
just standing around in here doing nothing,
for no reason.
Across the city, strange incidents start to
occur.
People who so much as knock into each other
while walking on the crowded New York streets
begin to brawl with one another on the ground,
while nobody around them even really acknowledges
that they’re doing it, let alone tries to
break them up.
Nearby, cars crash at the intersection, and
rather than getting out to exchange insurance
information, the irate drivers draw guns and
start to duel like bit-characters in an old
cowboy movie.
Nobody really seems to mind.
As if noticing a change in the wind, organized
crime rackets decide that secrecy isn’t
the way to go anymore.
Mob enforcers rob stores and shake down random
people in the streets, taking wallets, watches,
phones, and jewelry.
Criminals break into people’s homes and
start ransacking the place, stealing everything
from flat-screen TVs to priceless family heirlooms,
while their owners sit on the couch, seemingly
unable to even comprehend that something is
going wrong here.
But everything is still about to get a whole
lot worse.
The city breaks into riots and looting.
People battling in the streets.
News helicopters circle above, reporting the
chaos unfolding below them, but they do so
with an odd kind of detached calm, not really
comprehending the full scope of what’s happening
or why.
Just that a whole lot more is on fire now
than it was before.
How strange.
This is the moment when the SCP Foundation
realizes the meaning of The Specter’s pleading.
He really was being entirely unselfish, because
you see, The Specter isn’t just an extremely
devoted crime fighter, he’s the very personification
of the concept of fighting crime.
He can’t ever be locked up or contained,
because if you do so, then the very concept
of resisting crime fades from the human consciousness.
Order ceases to be and chaos reigns.
That’s why The Specter, also known as SCP-4494,
is classified as Archon - Meaning that he
can’t be contained, because the danger of
containing him would be far greater than the
danger of letting him roam around and do his
thing unhindered.
He maintains an amicable relationship with
the SCP Foundation after everything that happened,
willing to swoop in and help their agents
when they’re in a bind, and need a little
hand from a true hero.
And when he’s not fighting crime, he relaxes
in The Specter Cave by watching TV and playing
video games.
No, we’re not making that up.
Unsurprisingly, his favorite video games are
ones where you get to play as superheroes,
though he will occasionally indulge in some
Grand Theft Auto V - Just don’t expect him
to break any traffic laws while he’s playing,
thank you very much.
So if ever you feel afraid, or that the dark
forces that are all too human in this world
are marshaling against you, know this: You
don’t fight alone.
There’s a man in the shadows, ready to come
to your aid.
He’s a warrior for justice.
He’s a defender of the innocent.
But most of all, he is…
The Specter.
Now go check out “SCP-999 Tickle Monster
VS.
the Most Evil SCPs” and “SCP-999 and the
Most Wholesome SCPs” for more anomalies
that really just want to make the world a
better place!